to the young teenagers and other
students when you study science and you
start thinking about the human body you
know one of the first things that you're
taught is the body has a lot of parts
and we have our brain we have our
muscles and we have the various parts
inside the body you know the so called
organs and they teach you a lot about
these different parts of the body but
one of the most important things is how
the different parts of the body talk to
each other and how how does the brain
talk to the muscle to tell you to move
an arm for example okay we call that
synaptic or neuronal communication how
does your stomach talk to your pancreas
to cause hormones like insulin to
control the sugar that you're eating and
make sure that the right amount of sugar
goes throughout your body and then to
your brain so that your brain can be
thinking in a way because I hope you are
right now if you're listening to us that
that is it's it's those very basic
questions of cell to cell communication
in the body that professors suit off
Schekman and i have helped to understand